hey guys Ryan right here and I'm Dan
cybers we're gonna watch a trailer for a
game that you could say is growing it is
changing it's called the wolf quitting
the channel with the channel yeah okay
I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm staying forever evolved a co-op game
I like the idea the co-op game acted a
lot you could play us out at one of the
four hunters or you could play as a
monster yes
dude what yeah because we're going away
from like 4v4 I mean there's still gonna
be a lot of like you know players versus
players even teams Call of Duty will
forever be a thing but this is awesome
because it's just so different
yeah doing a lot of stuff where it's
asymmetrical where you have like one guy
that can like kill everybody
ha you know like what I've read about it
it sounds like gonna be ten times more
fun to be the monster and see yes it
does listen it like no one really talked
about the hunter reason they're just
like the monsters [ __ ] awesome or the
tutor least Goliath and Kraken Goliath
on the Kraken mmm right now and then
there's four classes right now let's
pull it up okay so trapper support medic
and assault class the assault class I
remember as a robot oh cool
I believe all right cool cool yeah all
right well let's watch this trailer that
was highly received at e3 wait crap the
supports the robot damn it Dan
vagina nice awesome four players first
one ah ah I get it
Oh sweetie are the craters of left for
dead
the hunters like pretty [ __ ] sweet
like the bow the environment looks okay
I remind you the actual alien game yeah
an alien whoa oh [ __ ]
I'd love to play as a mom I think that's
the cracking aah
oh my god laughter man hashtag hashtag
for viewpoint that game looks pretty
[ __ ] sweet I love the whole look of
everything a lot of Connor it is like a
science fiction like a dark science
fiction universe like it looks like
cinematic was and then the monster looks
scary but you could play as the [ __ ]
monster [ __ ] it's gonna be one of those
games where as like as the monster
you're gonna be like sneaking around and
following these hunters or I'm like
jumping down and I think all four
players have to beat the monster or the
monster just just to kill like one of
you guys I don't know the four i I think
well if I'm guessing right there's I'm
hopefully there's gonna be different
game modes but I would imagine like the
four hunters might respawn over and over
again and they just have to kill the
Kraken and then or the Goliath and then
the monster has to destroy whatever
objective that map has I'm sure okay so
they're like an assault thing ah damn I
want that I don't want that - dude that
game looks pretty [ __ ] sick thank you
guys for recommending that trailer if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the Rio rejects what up
here that's an invitation ah YouTube
annotation trysting and uh hey Dan why
don't we give you an annotation for your
channel Oh down here yeah hello well
there it is [ __ ] um that cyber channel
gaming channel you made a purple it's
purple
you don't like purple do you okay hey
Dan yeah um we just told people to
subscribe you know what I think we
should do next I make a guess yeah um
wishing mall high-fives yes yes yes yes
thanks guys
oh wait shoutouts all right here we go
virtual nan Gendo hey man calm down a
bunch of your videos
what with the hot chicks and Mexican
gangster whoo
and I was wondering shout-out please if
you ever giving me a shout-out semi link
please I love when you guys asked me to
sent you um virtual Nintendo uh no I
haven't given you a shout out yet I
definitely remember that name um what
does that mean in jindo I'm assuming
it's the off-brand of Nintendo are you
the off-brand of Nintendo ah if so can
you hand me a uh it's a vu Nintendo beat
you I get it again in jindo Genoveva
Nintendo vu agenda barrio Vario ah pink
since it's a honky Kong Donkey Kong
bunky bunk just vide condom does it ma
keycard sound like a Russian donkey
funky funky con Soviet Russia Kong
Donkey you that's like half Minnesota a
little mad Russian sorry let me just
open me just doesn't really go away
don't you know well yeah there's your
shout out buddy
hopefully you like your shout out some
people apparently request shout outs and
are not satisfied wow you guys are
ridiculous
got satisfied oh do we need to add the
shout out Garrity if you don't like our
shout out please level do another one
within 24 hours Bicknell 67 yo he said
awesome video guys keep them coming can
do can you have a shout out like now 67
yes but I I've talked to you before it
should be Bicknell 69 the problem and
instead of a B it should be a D dick now
69 guarantee you more laughs more
tension will go to your name people will
actually take interest and maybe check
out your channel so dick now 69 I would
definitely take that as a better route
if you really want to grow your YouTube
channel doesn't seem like you're focused
on because you don't really have a
thumbnail but yeah solid advice right as
always of course under size I want to
know if I got to a shout out I did find
out
video my friend Darren Ellis what's up
he left a long comment and then he said
I almost forgot ha I'm sorry um oh yeah
shout out maybe huh and and really this
hey don't don't worry Darren I got you
hey shut up yeah yeah dan the battery's
blinking Oh No Darren you're a last hope
before the battery dies damn it
please come to the address given at the
bottom of the screen is but we don't
know how to leave this apartment without
your help Darren we're trapped - we're
out of batteries Jesus Christ it's okay
Ryan boy could we get through this I
have Ritz crackers the roasted vegetable
huh
he's dead well or am I